so you're dupont in the late 1930s
you're a chemical company that's been
around for more than 100 years any
company that's existed for that amount
of time should have made a name for
itself ages ago but even though you're
doing well you just haven't really
popped off yet that was until 1938 when
a doctor accidentally discovers a
material called teflon that's so
versatile so useful so unbelievable that
it changes the course of dupont forever
you know teflon the stuff used in
non-stick pans
well good thing it's teflon
made with a chemical called c8s teflon
revolutionized the cooking industry for
people all over the world they won't
stink that's why it's called
nonstick
i don't know what nonstick means it
takes is sweetheart but
me
and teflon and ca went on to be used in
a ton of other consumer goods popcorn
bags waterproof jackets dental floss
food containers make up pizza boxes all
have some form of c8s or c8 derivatives
in them
the only problem was ca and most of the
chemicals like it are extremely toxic
and are what's known as forever
chemicals because they never break down
but what the public doesn't know they'll
keep buying so we'll just keep this
between us
now that's cooking
so ca became widely used in a bunch of
products that come in contact with
people's food and making ca takes a lot
of work a lot of work that produces a
lot of chemical waste that we have to
get rid of somewhere so why not dump it
in the waterways around our factories i
mean come on you're not gonna pay for
expensive responsible chemical waste
disposal when there's a perfectly good
river right there next to your factory
so over the decades ca spread from the
rivers into farms into tap water into
the animals that we eat and ultimately
into us
to where today
99.7 of americans have c8 in their
bloodstream with c8 being linked to at
least six diseases including testicular
cancer and kidney cancer
so how did an obscure chemical company
get into the bloodstream of nearly every
single american and most importantly how
did they get away with it just asking
for a friend
this is how dupont poisoned the world
oh well good thing it's teflon
[Music]
even burned food won't stick to teflon
so it's always easy to clean
cookware never needs scouring if it has
dupont teflon
[Music]
out of chemical research come the
thousands of products that contribute to
better living
the dupont company maker of better
things for better living
dupont started in 1802 in delaware it
was the brainchild of a french-american
chemist and industrialist named
evening dupont in new moon
okay not bad i can't get the uh sound
but close enough and dupont started out
as a gunpowder mill and production
company out of all things you had a lot
of business supplying the wars that
broke out throughout the 19th century
by the time the american civil war hit
dupont was the biggest supplier of
gunpowder to the us military
so dupont started out as war profiteers
which if you've seen our war profiteer
videos you know that this can be a very
lucrative business to be in
ironically enough the founder of dupont
came to america to escape the french
revolution but it was never enough
you lived and breathed innovation which
led to the development of hundreds of
different chemicals and materials over
the years kevlar used in bulletproof
armor today lycra nylon all these
revolutionary materials that would go on
to change the world were all made by
duponts
even your carpeting and dupont makes all
that
but something was missing so you started
buying up all the gunpowder businesses
you could find it was so extreme that by
1912 your shopping spree caught the
government's attention because you
started turning the gunpowder business
into your own monopoly and as soon as
you were declared a monopoly you were
ordered to divest from the industry and
your age of controlling the gunpowder
business was over without the cash cow
that was gunpowder you needed something
else to bring in revenue and since
dupont were already experts at chemistry
you got involved in almost every
chemical related industry in the book
but everything changed in 1938's the
world was on the verge of world war ii
and dr plunkett whom we talked about
earlier accidentally discovers teflon
[Music]
why don't most people know about this
dark side of dupont because dupont is a
master at branding however designing a
profitable brand can be really difficult
and expensive luckily today there's a
one-stop shop for all your graphic
design and branding needs and that one
soft shop is canva canva allows you to
make these amazing professional looking
instagram stories youtube thumbnails
youtube intro animations slide decks
desktop wallpapers infographics even
full-blown videos it's honestly pretty
insane how much you can do canva has
thousands of easy to use customizable
templates made by professional designers
stuff that actually looks shockingly
good
it's super intuitive to use you can work
on mobile or desktop canva basically
makes it impossible for you to make
something ugly and canva even has a
completely free version as well but you
really want to get canva pro or else
you're going to miss out on a ton of
tools that are going to save you hours
of tedious work one of my favorite
features of canva pro is their canva
content planner which allows you to
schedule the stuff you make in canva to
go live on almost all the major social
media platforms social media schedulers
usually cost around the same amount as
camera pro anyways so this feature alone
pays for itself my other favorite
feature is their instant one-click
background remover removing a background
is usually a really frustrating process
you have to do manually in a more
advanced editing tool but this one is in
one click
so if you're interested in trying out
camera pro they've got you with a free
45-day trial with the link below a ton
of my friends use canva pro and you can
always downgrade to their free version
so you have nothing to lose give it a
try for free for 45 days by using the
link in the video description below
thanks to canva for sponsoring this
video
makers of better things for better
living
through chemistry
nearly everything in our daily lives is
improved by chemistry from
transportation to the clothes we wear
chemistry helps bring us better food
makes our homes more beautiful more
comfortable
helps protect our health
and adds to the enjoyment of our leisure
time
teflon is made using a chemical called
c8 also known as pfoa or this long word
being that it repels water oil stains
and can withstand a lot of heat teflon
was perfect to coat the tanks and
military vehicles the army was going to
need for world war ii instead of rain
mud and the elements damaging and
corroding tanks over time it would
simply slide off the surface if it was
coated in teflon the c8 in teflon was
important to keep the material from
clumping while it was being applied and
at the same time ca or pfoa was seen as
completely safe this new wonder material
could change the world but there was a
problem teflon production in the 1940s
was expensive so expensive that making
everyday items like pans or rain jackets
was unthinkable so to make enough teflon
to meet the growing demand while keeping
expenses as low as possible you would
need an affordable source of c8s and
that's where 3m came in
around the same time a french engineer
named mark gragar had the idea of
coating all his fishing gear in teflon
to keep it from getting tangled no one
really knows if this ever worked because
at the exact same time his wife had an
even better idea that took the spotlight
teflon coated pants and pots cooking
equipment that wouldn't need to be
scrubbed or soaked to get clean people
could just wipe the food off with a damp
cloth and so teflon pans were born and
it would change the course of the food
industry forever
suddenly the world realized all the
possibilities that came with teflon and
the manufacturing and distribution of it
skyrocketed some people use a little oil
or butter when they cook so that things
don't stick to the pan
but i use
polytetrafluoroethylene
some sports call it nonstick for short
[Music]
now that's cooking so you sat back and
watched the fortune start rolling in the
world started going crazy for non-stick
pants self-cleaning ovens and teflon
coated furniture but you knew this craze
was unsustainable you see even though
the us government didn't recognize pfoa
as a dangerous chemical both dupont and
3m knew it was potentially toxic with
every batch of ca you bought from 3m the
instructions for disposing it were the
same incinerate
[Music]
had an inkling available eventually
something was going to go wrong but that
didn't stop you from making millions
from the new teflon coded inventions
that were being created almost every day
so how did dupont go about following
those instructions to dispose of c8s
dumping it into the planet of course in
one town alone parkersburg west virginia
the dupont teflon manufacturing plant
dumped hundreds of thousands of pounds
of c8 into the ohio river and that was
just the beginning
what's this silver stone coated fry pan
doing in an oven
letting you know that durable non-stick
silverstone is available on bakeware
such as cake pans
muffin pans
cookie sheets and loaf pans
and since most foods won't stick to
silverstone cleaning up is quick and
easy
so let silverstone take you out of the
frying pan and into bakeware
[Music]
because the process to manufacture
teflon had been so expensive to begin
with you needed to keep expenses as low
as possible and dumping ca into rivers
and unprotected landfills was so much
cheaper than actually disposing it the
right way or building incinerators but
dumping c8 into unlike pits and rivers
meant it spread rather quickly so within
a few years pfoa chemicals has seeped
into the groundwater surrounding
parkersburg and nearby towns the same
groundwater that was being used to
produce tap water ready to drink for
more than a hundred thousand
and 3m had your suspicions but you
didn't want to find out whether or not
they were true i mean if you really
didn't know c8 was toxic there would
always be some plausible deniability the
i didn't know so you can't blame me card
that the government always pulls but it
got to a point where researchers at
dupont just couldn't let their curiosity
go and in 1961 they started secret
medical studies on pfoa and c8s behind
closed doors more than two decades after
mass production of teflon started and
what they found was horrifying c8 the
same chemical that had been marketed as
completely safe for decades was
extremely toxic to human and animals
exposure to ca increased the size of
liver in rats rabbits and dogs and if it
had this effect on animals who knows
what it would have had on humans
but the profits were just too good to
switch off so the sale of teflon
continued and the research results were
carefully locked up for a few years it
looked like you could keep your secrets
that was until dupont researchers
discovered crazy high concentrations of
pfoa in your workers own blood and the
race was on it was only a matter of time
before something happened that exposed
the dangers of pfoas so to make sure the
victims stay quiet you had to get to
them first so dupont started watching
and monitoring their workers in secrets
in 1981 3m reported that pfoa caused
birth defects and rats so you reassigned
pregnant women away from the teflon
manufacturing line and carefully
observed their babies for any sort of
defects and when two out of seven babies
were born with eye defects well you deny
any and all responsibility then in 1984
another report came out that pfoa dust
was getting through the factory chimneys
settling on land far away from the
factory and had gone into the local
water supply but again you do not
disclose this damning information
by the 90s your pfoa business is worth
more than a billion dollars this is
generational wealth only a few could
dream of and you weren't just gonna give
that up oversea possibly being dangerous
so teflon sales and ads kept growing
chemistry is the is the practice of
magic
people think of teflon they think of
frying pans teflon is not one thing
putting teflon on a surface will stop
bugs from crawling up trees they'll fall
right off the tree
teflon is a chain lube this is something
i've come up with for bicycles you know
only dupont makes teflon and you can use
in satellites on fabrics or leather
when's the last time you heard about a
leather renko
you can let your imagination run wild
it's not often that you get to make
something new in this world while dupont
kicked the can down the road once more
except now decades of ca exposure had
passed and its effects were finally
starting to show
[Music]
perfect eggs don't always start with the
egg
they start with silverstone
it's the most durable nonstick surface
ever made by dupont and just to prove
our point we'll cook some eggs with
these letters and still not hurt
silverstone's non-stick performance see
so no matter what you're making
parkersburg west virginia the late 90s
a farmer by the name wilbur tennant was
going through something strange he had
come across two dead deer and two deck
housed at a nearby river the deers have
blood coming out of their noses
i've taken two dead deer
and two dead cattle off of this ripple
right here they tell me the deer died
with hammering disease the blood run out
of their nose now their mouth but
they've never dnr
has never checked into it
any epa or the state of west virginia
should try to cover this stuff up
coincidentally over the past few years
153 of his 600 cows have been found dead
all with the same mo they show bleeding
from their noses and has signs of
serious illness and damage to their
internal organs all the cows had access
to that same river
a year later he filmed what happened to
his cows
she said henry's out the nose this is
153 of these animals that i've lost on
this farm
coincidentally not long before the cows
started getting sick the farmer's
brother has sold 66 acres of land to
dupont to be used as a non-hazardous
landfill also coincidentally the river
led upstream to a factory known as the
dupont washington works it didn't take a
genius to put two and two together so he
went to dupont but obviously they denied
everything what was even stranger was
that whenever he went to anyone in town
for help doctors vets and even local
politicians and lawyers no one was
willing to help him
vets wouldn't go to see wilbur's cows
lifelong friends of wilbur and his
family ignore them on the streets they
had to change their church four times so
wilbur reached out to an environmental
lawyer outside of parkersburg named rob
billitz who spent most of his career
representing corporations like dupont's
the laura took the case and together
they traced the cattle's illness to a
pipe clearly labeled duponts that was
pumping a green bubbly liquid into the
creek from which wilbur's cows drank
literally like something out of a movie
so in 1999 rob billet and will return it
filed a federal lawsuit against dupont
as dupont this was a corporate nightmare
for you your charade was getting
unveiled here was a complete nobody an
unknown cattle farmer who could
potentially destroy your entire business
so you put the blame on him it wasn't
your non-hazardous waste that was making
his cow sick wilbur and his family just
didn't know how to take care of the cows
if the cows were dying it was their own
faults now on paper some small time
farmers should have given up pretty
easily when bombarded with endless legal
fees and paperwork but even if he wanted
to give up his lawyer refused to throw
in the towel then billet found the
smoking gun in one letter from dupont to
the epa billet found a reference to a
cryptically named chemical pfoa no one
at his firm knew what it was but billet
and his client were getting close to the
truth so when they came asking for
documents dupont had on the subjects
dupont outright refused they may have
found the smoking gun but dupont wasn't
going to hand up a signing stamp
confession until they had no choice
billa got a court order compelling
dupont to hand over all the information
they had on pfoa and dupont submitted
more than 110 000 pages
if you can't suppress the truth you can
at least hide it between 100 000 pages
and hope it's never found but billet
recognized the tactic and knew he was
getting close and by the end of the year
2000 he had everything he needed a
document explaining that in 1990 dupont
had knowingly dumped toxic pfoa waste
into the landfill near wilbur's property
knowing it drained into their land
wilbur tennant and his family settled
the farmer's fight was over but for the
lawyer in his own words he said quotes i
was irritated end quotes irritated that
dupont could just get away with a slap
on the wrist and a simple fine to pay so
the battle was just beginning
there was one email in particular where
after i had alerted the company that i
had finally kind of started figuring
this out and i was aware that pfoa
was what was in the landfill and it was
what the cows were drinking and it was
in the public water supply there was a
an email where the
council made a reference to f him
uh he knows about this now and eff him
[Music]
unless you want to develop a strong
attachment to dinner
choose a dupont non-stick
because whether you spend a little or a
lot you're guaranteed of getting a
quality non-stick certified by dupont
[Music]
the farmer's case had opened the
floodgates and billet was just getting
started under the toxic substances
control acts the epa could only test
chemicals if it was provided with
evidence of harm and the farmer's cow
had given billet exactly that so in 2005
dupont settled with the epa on a 16.5
million dollar fine for hiding the
toxicity and spread of pfoa but that
wasn't the end more and more people from
parkersburg started coming forward as
they found out about pfoa and the
effects it had on humans and animals
joseph kyger a night school teacher
joined billa's team as lee plaintiff he
had liver disease possibly related to
pfoa in his drinking water and when he
tried talking to the west virginia
department of natural resources the
parkersburg state department of
environmental protection the water
division the local health department he
was either shut down or lied to every
single time but the major breakthrough
came when billet and his team finished a
new medical study of 70 000 people it
proved that pfoa was in fact linked to
at least six diseases including cancer
and thyroid disease and that dupont had
at least known about the cancer for
years all of a sudden thousands of
people were now standing to sue duponts
[Music]
[Music]
there are three brands you can depend on
no matter what you spend on don't get
stuck
it ain't no deal without that don't
stick seal here's what you want
because of the study dupont was now
faced with a lawsuit in criminal
investigation from the epa and was
ordered to phase out the production of
c8 in the u.s over a generous 10 years
during the course of our lawsuit as
we're providing more of this information
to the u.s epa and the u.s epa is
getting more and more concerned about it
they've brought a lawsuit they've
started actually a criminal
investigation
in 2005.
dupont eventually settles our case in
west virginia
they also then settle the the case that
the u.s epa had brought against them
and one of the things they also agreed
to do is they announced that they will
have a 10-year phase-out
of any further manufacturing or use of
pfoa in the united states dupont was on
the verge of losing its most profitable
products but as dupont you had a very
simple solution to this since every
forever chemical had to be regulated
individually you could theoretically
switch out the chemical composition of
c8 a bit and call it a brand new thing
that isn't banned
enter gen x a less toxic version of c8s
so buy a new spin-off company called
chemours since the branding of dupont
was damaged
the dupont company spun off
the division that had been making teflon
related materials they for they spun it
off into a new company called chemours
and the camour's company took over a lot
of these plants including the
parkersburg plant that had been making
these floral products they shifted over
to a new material which they are
referring to now as gen x
chemours literally just took over the
exact same plants that just a few years
earlier were pumping extremely toxic
pfoa into the environment by 2015 all
production of pfoa had stopped just as
the production of gen x was booming
despite the lawsuits dupont stayed
profitable and in 2017 it merged with
the dow chemical company to form dow
duponts the new face of the chemical
industry worth at least 130 billion
dollars
dupont also has an agricultural chemical
and seed division called pioneer hybrid
that was later spun off into a company
called corteva they sell pesticides and
genetically modify seeds much like the
company monsanto which is perhaps one of
the most controversial corporations on
the planets but that is a very long dark
story that deserves its own
feature-length 40-minute plus
documentary that's going to come out
next week or will be already out by the
time you're watching this called
monsanto the company that owns the
world's food supply but here's the thing
stories like monsanto are going to be
some of the darkest most machiavellian
videos i have ever made imagine these
videos taken to a further extreme where
we're going to uncover how the elite
really think that you're never going to
hear them emits because if the elite did
admit this they would either be pillaged
or sent to the guillotine or at the bare
minimum they will have more competition
to deal with so that's why you're never
going to hear about this stuff anywhere
else you're not going to hear from your
parents or friends because they're most
likely not in private circles with
powerful people and you're not going to
hear it from your business professors
because they're probably broke but we're
going to break it down here in all its
machiavellian glory but the thing is
just like dupont if i release these
teachings to the public i'm definitely
going to get cancelled so we're not
going to be releasing these to the
public all you have to do if you want to
get this education that they will never
teach you in business school is to click
the join button below right next to the
subscribe button if you don't see the
button there's a link in the video
description below once you sign up
you'll get access to this exclusive
documentary when it comes out or you'll
get it immediately if it's already out
by the time you're watching this and
unlike an nba i'm not going to charge
you 55 000 to 161 000 to learn this
stuff nope just five dollars a month for
longer documentaries of the same videos
you love that you will not be able to
see anywhere else and this five dollars
a month is just to cover the cost to
produce these videos give it a try for a
month and if you don't think this
knowledge is worth it email me and i
will personally refund you the money
pause the video and click that join
button below right now
what's up guys we're in france right now
paris here's the eiffel tower i'm in
like the middle floor very appropriate
being that the founder of dupont is for
france hope you guys enjoy the video if
you're new here subscribe for more
business documentaries just like this
one every single week for free and
that's gonna wrap it up keep sharpening
that mind stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
you